hello everybody and welcome to a machine
learning with the Python programming
language tutorial videos series in this
series we're going to be talking about
machine learning and basically I argue
that really a machine learning is kind
of like this buzzword that everybody
kind of puts up on this pedestal it
makes it sound like it's a lot more
complicated than it is machine learning
is actually pretty simple especially
when we break it down into little parts
it's a lot like programming in general
which you know from the outside looking
it looks really complex and confusing
but we can break down every program into
really basic steps that just make a
whole lot of sense to anybody so machine
learning is very much the same way and I
think that machine learning is maybe
even a compare the name because when we
call something machine learning it
sounds like the machine is somehow like
learning all on its own or something and
for the most part machine learning is
what we call supervised machine learning
where we're kind of guiding the machine
to maybe how to approach a task and
there is a form of machine learning
called unsupervised learning which is
more along the lines of what most people
probably envision when they hear this
term machine learning but really a
better better term for machine learning
would be just machine classification
because that's all machine learning is
doing it's just
automated classification and that's not
to be confused though there is a form of
machine learning it's a form of
supervised learning called literally
classification but all machine learning
is classification even unsupervised
learning say a form of unsupervised
learning is clustering where we just
throw a bunch of random data at the
Machine and we say you know put this in
your groups however you see fit and it's
going to put it in groups or
classifications right it won't have a
good name for those groups it'll be like
you know group a1 or something but its
classification all right and if you
think about it then we do classification
ourselves to learn about subjects so an
example would be machine learning in
general right how is machine learning
typically taught well we first people
start with the concepts the basics right
so they say okay there's two fun
machine learning you've got supervised
unsupervised supervises where we kind of
guide as the scientists we guide the
machine you've got you know
classification is an example and that's
where we label the data we know the
labels to the data and we give it a
testing set we know the answer is all
this kind of stuff and the Machine
doesn't blah blah and then you've got
unsupervised learning which is where we
don't guide the Machine and that kind of
thing so people kind of take this in
classification and we start kind of
learning about it's very Aristotelian
right where we just want to classify
things as humans that's just kind of how
we learn when in reality classification
while it's really powerful it's not
exactly the only way that humans learn
so we learn by classification because
it's actually it's a good trait to have
but if you really look at things even
scientifically things aren't really
black and white they're more of an array
and so to an extent classification is
useful and to an extent it's not and you
kind of need a mixture of both
classifications good for us because we
can make quick snap judgments based on
classification whereas machines are
actually capable of processing this kind
of more of an array of data faster than
we are so they're probably better at
that and I think that's kind of where
unsupervised learning is is heading
right now so that's pretty cool but
anyway the philosophical debate aside
we're going to be talking about
programming machine learning so what
what you'll find when you as we go down
this path is that actually machine
learning really simple right for the
most part you'll never write your own
machine learning algorithm there's
already just gobs of machine learning
algorithms out there for you and we're
going to be using scikit-learn with
Python and socket learn has a ton of
these algorithms pre-made for you so you
just use one of theirs that's the easy
part okay for the most part that's the
easy part
actually what you'll find that you spend
the most time doing with machine
learning is actually acquiring the data
so whatever data you want to do machine
learning on you have to get that data
somehow then you need to figure out how
you're going to kind of like organize
that
data and so like for example acquiring
data like we're going to be using we're
going to be doing the machine loading on
stocks and we're going to analyze a
bunch of fundamentals of stocks and see
if there's anything that we can kind of
derive from the fundamentals that make a
stock outperform the market and so
that's what we're going to use machine
learning for and so first we have to
acquire all this fundamental data well
as it turns out there's as far as I know
no really great easy way to acquire this
data so you have couple sources you've
got Yahoo or you could use literally sec
Gove's edgar but i don't know how many
of you have seen edgar will go through
edgar actually probably in the third
video just to show you because edgar has
a lot of really awesome data right
they're just so rich in data but the
structure is very bad and so it makes it
very difficult to actually acquire that
data so you're going to find that you're
spending a lot of time acquiring the
data and then even more time labeling
the data if you're doing a supervised
learning which most of you probably will
be so acquiring the labeling the data
and then basically structuring the data
in such a way that you can feed it
through a machine learning algorithm
again that's mostly for if you're doing
unsupervised learning or I mean
supervised learning but even an
unsupervised learning you're probably
going to want to like at least normalize
the data or something like that to have
a little bit higher chance of success so
in reality as I'll show you guys uh
probably in the next video we'll
actually do we'll we'll do a real
machine learning algorithm and I'll show
you how friggin simple it is to do
machine learning the hard part is
getting that data structuring that data
and kind of feeding through that data or
even labeling that data that's really
the hard part and so that's what I want
to show you guys how to do but we're
going to will go all the way through
from you know premise basically our
premises we're going to try to figure
out any if there's any fundamentals with
stocks all the way to the end so the
last thing I want to talk about before
we go ahead and get all of our packages
that we need is what is machine learning
useful for so like I said machine
learning isn't this thing that we can
just apply to anything right the goal
with unsupervised learning is
just that is that we could just take a
huge dataset we don't need to label it
do evening a dataset just like throw it
at the Machine and have that machine
just returned to us all kinds of
wonderful insights that's really
difficult
um and so far no one really has that
Google just did acquire a company I
think it called deep mind and what they
did is they've got an unsupervised
learning algorithm that they just they
throw a video game at the algorithm and
they were like you know there's these
really basic games just a real 2d arcade
like games like pac-man it wasn't
pac-man but like like pac-man and they
just basically threw the game at the
unsupervised algorithm and didn't really
say anything more and the algorithm
actually learned how to play the game
and do it really really well and one of
the most eerie examples was there's a
boxing game and the unsupervised
learning algorithm figured out how to
like pin the other guy against the ropes
and just like just wail the hell out of
them so uh so a little more eerie
example of machine learning and a lot of
people are definitely uh fearful of
machine learning I know just recently
Stephen Hawking came out and said that
we need to fear it I don't really think
so not really a machine learning can
give us insights but they still doesn't
really act on those insights and you
still need this like notion of oneness
or like pure autonomy away from being
able us to just pull the plug or
whatever it may be one day that'll
happen who knows I do think that if you
took all of the world's data and shoved
it through an unsupervised learning
algorithm with the goal of finding how
to better the world probably the return
would be to remove all the humans so
that's true
so maybe we should fear this and maybe
you shouldn't take part in this video
because you're gonna learn how to
program your machine overlords so I
don't know it's on you
so anyways uh that side let's go ahead
and get started so uh at the initial
outset I think what else we're probably
also going to need pandas but we'll get
to pandas when we get there before we do
what we want to do in this next video we
need the following packages we need
matplotlib we need numpy
and we need so I can't learn so if you
don't already have matplotlib you can
either go to matplotlib org and go to
the downloads and get it or if you're on
a Windows machine the easiest way to
acquire packages is with this guy's lfd
diet you see out whatever I put this
link pretty much in all my videos where
we have to download stuff it's super
easy you just come here it's a Windows
binary so 64 bit here 32 bit here boom
done so really easy to get it
same thing with numpy get numpy I will
put I'll put all these links in the
description so if you need the links
just head over there this is numpy zip
so obviously this would be a setup top I
example to install or again this is
binary and then finally scikit-learn org
or again you can get the binary here so
just depending on where you are also
obviously if you're on like Linux or
even Mac OS you'll have to install your
value your typical ways loose Linux you
should be able to just apt-get basically
all of these I don't really all these
are get a gettable anyway so once you
have those um the next thing that we'd
want to make sure we can do is just just
do something like this like import
matplotlib port map put live import
numpy and then a import SK learn so just
like type those things out and then go
ahead and just press f5 to run it if
you're in a regular idle or IDE and as
long as nothing you know catastrophic
occurs you've installed everything
correctly so I'm going to go ahead and
just cut the video here where everyone
downloads and installs all of these
packages and I'll resume the video again
when assuming you guys have all of this
installed and you're not getting any
errors at the imports and what we'll be
doing is actually writing a machine
learning algorithm for a number
recognition so if anybody remembers we
did a optical recognition basically of
numbers in one of my other videos we
basically we coded that
lately ourselves so that was our own
machine learning algorithm relatively
inefficient compared to what we'll see
here where this basically learns and
gives you the answer all all within
really quick quick order so anyways but
that's what we'll be doing so you'll see
an example of that so we'll actually do
some machine learning in the next video
so two videos and about what 13 minutes
and you'll have your first machine
learning done you probably quick there
and just say you know how to do machine
learning
so anyways please don't anyway so stay
tuned the next video if you have any
questions or comments any trouble
getting this downloaded and installed
and all that let me know I'll do my best
to help you guys out for matplotlib if
you are you know totally new to Python
and you try to download matplotlib let's
see where we hit matplotlib right here
um you're gonna need date util most
likely pi parsing 6 and if you've not
installed like any other package you'll
need setup tools as well so it's likely
that some of you guys are going to be
like uh it says another module is needed
whenever that it says that you need that
module so you know head over here get
the module or get it however you
typically get modules so anyways that's
it for this one
question comments below as always thanks
for watching things for all the support
of subscriptions until next time to
easily follow along to the next part you
can either click on the link in the
video if you have annotations turned on
or you can follow via the playlist link
in the description